A GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE I WANT
TO WELCOME ALL OF YOU TO PRIVACY
AND CONSUMER PROTECTION TODAY IS
JUNE TWENTY FIFTH.
TWENTY NINETEEN WE HAVE A TOTAL
OF SIX BILLS ON OUR AGENDA THREE
OF WHICH ARE ON PROPOSED CONSENT --
WE DO NOT HAVE A QUORUM YET BUT
WE CAN START AS A SUB COMMITTEE
AND I SEE SENATOR -- CHIANG HERE
SO AT THIS TIME I LIKE TO INVITE
HER TO COME.
UP THAT PRESENT HER BILL IN FACT
THIS IS THE THE LING LING SHOW
TODAY.
SO ANYTIME YOU'RE READY YOU MAY
PROCEED.
WONDERFUL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR I
I APOLOGIZE FOR MY BOYS HAVE
BEEN COUGHING A LOT FOR THE PAST
COUPLE DAYS BUT THANK YOU AGAIN
MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
FIRST I DO WANT TO NOTE THAT I
WILL BE AMENDING THE BILL TOOK
THEM COMMERCIAL U. S. OPERATORS
AS OUTLINED IN THE ANALYSIS.
AND I WANT TO THANK OF MR
CHAIRING A COMMITTEE STAFFER
WORKING WITH MY OFFICE ON THAT.
SB SIX FORTY EIGHT REQUIRES
DRONE OPERATORS WHO ARE INVOLVED
IN AN ACCIDENT THAT RESULT IN
PERSONAL INJURY OR PROPERTY
DAMAGE TO MEDIATE LEE LANDED
PRONE AT THE NEAREST LOCATION TO
PROVIDE THEIR NAME.
ADDRESS EMAIL ADDRESS AND VALID
ID TO THE INJURED INDIVIDUAL OR
THE OWNER OF THE DAMAGE PROPERTY.
THE FAA PROJECTS THAT THERE WILL
BE AN INCREASE OF RECREATIONAL
DRUGS FROM AN ESTIMATED ONE
POINT ONE MILLION IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN TO TWO POINT FOUR
MILLION BY.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO DESPITE THE
NUMEROUS PRACTICAL APPLICATIONS
FOR DRONES THERE A PUBLIC SAFETY
CONCERNS AS MORE DRONES ENTERED
THE PUBLIC AIRSPACE.
DRONES OR UNMANNED AIRCRAFT
SYSTEMS YOU ASK CAN INVADE
PERSONAL SPACE AND CAUSE
PERSONAL INJURY AND PROPERTY
DAMAGE.
AND THE STORY I KNOW MISTER
CHAIR IS A VERY FAMILIAR WITH
THIS BUT IN OCTOBER TWENTY
SIXTEEN A DRONE CRASHED INTO
ELECTRICAL WIRES IN WEST
HOLLYWOOD.
KNOCKING ONE OF THEM TO THE
GROUND THE DOWNED WIRE CUT OFF
POWER FOR NEARLY SEVEN HUNDRED
CALIFORNIA SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON CUSTOMERS FOR THREE HOURS.
AND WITHIN MY DISTRICT OF THE
CITY OF CHINO HILLS STANDS THAT
BAPS SHRI SWAMINARAYAN --
MUNDHIR IN INTRICATE TO
TRADITIONALLY DESIGN HINDU
TEMPLE THAT HAS BECOME AN
ARCHITECTURAL AND CULTURAL
LANDMARK IN THE AREA.
UNFORTUNATELY LEADERS WITHIN THE
MANDIR HAVE.
HAVE NOTIFIED ME THAT THEY HAVE
BEEN VICTIMS OF IRRESPONSIBLE
DRONE OPERATORS WHO CAUSED
DAMAGE TO THE BEAUTIFUL
ARCHITECTURE.
AND EVERY INCIDENT THAT HAS
OCCURRED OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS
HAVE CONSISTED THE DRONE
OPERATOR. TO MANY THEIR
EQUIPMENT BACK AND NOT LEAVING
INFORMATION TO ACCEPT FALL.
UNDER CURRENT LAW MOTOR VEHICLE
DRIVERS ARE REQUIRED TO STOP AND
PROVIDE ID AND CONTACT INFO IF
THEY ARE INVOLVED IN A CAR
ACCIDENT THAT CAUSES INJURY IN
OUR PROPERTY DAMAGE.
SB SIX FORTY PROMOTES USER
RESPONSIBILITY AND PROTECT
PUBLIC SAFETY BY APPLYING THE
SAME PRINCIPLES UNDERPINNING.
VEHICLE HADN'T RUN LAWSUIT
DRONES AND AGAIN LIKE TO THANK
MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE.
WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO TURN IT
OVER TO MY WITNESS WHO WERE
GOING TO EXPLAIN HOW THE USE OF
DRONES HAS AFFECTED OUR LOCAL
LANDMARK IN WITH ME I HAVE
COTHAM.
A PATEL PUBLIC AFFAIRS LEASE ON
FOR BAPS.
FOREMAN -- SWAMINARAYAN US SONS
OF REPRESENTING THE CHINO HILLS
BE A P. S..
P. A. P. S. TREES WOMAN ARE AND
MAN DEAR.
THANKS VERY MUCH FIRST WHEN AS
PLEASE WELCOME.
HELLO -- I'M GOT THEM TO TELL
AND I'M REPRESENTING A SENATOR
MENTIONED AT BAPS WHICH IS -- TO
A HINDU DENOMINATION OF US --
ONE SUNSTEIN CHINO HILLS -- SO
WE'RE HERE TO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR SENATOR SENATORS
HANGS BILL SB -- SIX FOUR EIGHT
OUR TEMPLATE YOU KNOW HILLS
WHICH IS TRADITIONAL IN BOTH
DESIGN AND ARCHITECTURE HAS HAD
MANY INSTANCES IN WHICH THEY
RESPONSIBLE OPERATION OF THERE
MUST BE RESPONSIBLE JOHN
OPERATORS.
HAVE DAMAGE OUR PROPERTY IN
SYDNEY SIGNIFICANT WAYS -- OUR
TEMP OUR TEMPLE FEATURES
THOUSANDS OF INTRICATE CARVINGS
BOTH ON THE INSIDE AND THE
OUTSIDE AND THAT MAKES IT A
POPULAR LANDMARK FOR JOHN
OPERATORS -- DESPITE SIGNS
PROHIBITING JONES ON THE
PROPERTY WE'VE HAD COUNTLESS
OCCASIONS IN WHICH THE OPERATORS
FLY FROM ADJACENT LOTS OF FROM
ACROSS THE STREET -- WITHOUT
GOOD VISIBILITY AND THEY TRY TO
FLY THEIR DRONES AND THEY'VE HIT --
THEY'VE DAMAGE OUR PROPERTY OUR
TEMPLE SPIRES ARE PILLARS OUR
WATER FEATURES AND MANY OTHER
ASKED -- PARTS OF OUR BUILDING
IN EACH OF THESE SITUATIONS
WE'VE NEVER HAD ANY RECOURSE AND
THE DRONE OPERATORS IMMEDIATELY.
DEMAND THEY'RE DRAWN BACK AND
OCCASIONALLY THEY HAVE A
THREATEN TO CALL THE COPS IF WE
WERE UNABLE -- TO SO IT NOT ONLY
ARE THEY DAMAGING OUR PROPERTY
BUT THEY'RE ALSO THREATENING US
AND IT'S ALSO VERY DIFFICULT
OCCASIONALLY FOR US TO GET THE
DRONES FROM SOME OF THE
LOCATIONS IN WHICH THEY'RE
CRASHING THEM -- AND THAT OUR
TEMPLE WHICH HAS -- THE
INTRICATE CARVINGS ON THE DAMAGE
THAT'S DONE TO THEM IS ACTUALLY --
IMPOSSIBLE FOR US TO FIX BECAUSE
THEIR THE TRADITIONAL HINDU MIND
THERE IS -- THE CARVINGS ARE
DONE BY ARTISANS AND SOME OF THE
STONE AGE MOST OF THE SUN IS
ACTUALLY SHIP FROM INDIA SO.
IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT WE COULD
JUST FIX REALLY EASILY THE
DAMAGES REALLY REALLY
SIGNIFICANT -- AND AGAIN IN EACH
SITUATION AT THE JOHN OPERATORS
THAT THERE'S NO RECOURSE AND
THEY THEY'RE THEY'RE NOT
COOPERATIVE AT ALL WITH US --
AND WE'VE DONE EVERYTHING WE CAN
TO PREVENT THIS SO AGAIN WE
DON'T ALLOW THIS ON OUR PROPERTY
BUT WE CAN'T STOP THEM FROM --
FLYING STARTING THEIR JONES FROM
OUTSIDE OF THE PROPERTY IN
FLYING -- ON TO OURS SO.
WE WE'VE JUST -- WE'VE SPOKEN
WITH CENTER CHAINS OFFICE AND
THEIR OF THEIR AND REALLY NO
SOLUTIONS AND AGAIN.
WHILE WE WOULD PREFER TO HAVE
OBVIOUSLY NO JONES BE ABLE TO
OPERATE ON NEAR THE TEMPLE I
THINK THAT THIS IS A REALLY GOOD
OPPORTUNITY AND IT PROVIDES US
TO HAVE OUR FIRST STEP IN
TOWARDS.
IN TERMS OF BEING ABLE TO HAVE
SOME TYPE OF RECOURSE.
THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
BEFORE WE GO TO OUR NEXT WITNESS
CAN WE ESTABLISH QUORUM -- FOR
THE MEETING PLEASE MA'AM
SECRETARY CHAO HERE [inaudible]
KILEY.
OUR QUE HAN [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
CALDERON [inaudible]
GABRIEL [inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
I NGUYEN [inaudible]
SMITH [inaudible]
WICKS.
WE DO A QUORUM WE ALL CAN ALSO
TAKE UP THE CONSENT AGENDA -- IF --
I COULD HAVE A MOTION.
FOR THE ODD MAN SIX THREE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
CHAO I TELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE BAUER QUE HAN.
OKAY HAND I BERMAN.
CALDERON [inaudible]
GABRIEL [inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
IRWIN -- WHEN I?
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE SMITH
SMITH I WICKS.
VERY GOOD THAT WE DO HAVE -- SIX
VOTES -- CONSENT CORRECT THAT
YOU HAVE SEVENTY I THE CONSENT
AGENDA IS OUT AND THAT'S ITEM
FOUR FIVE AND SIX AND THEY'RE
ALL.
SENATOR CHAINS BILLS SO WITH
THAT -- LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT TO
WITNESS PLEASE WELCOME CHAIR
MEMBERS KEEP BELT WITH CAPITAL
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION FOR UNMANNED VEHICLE
SYSTEMS INTERNATIONAL THROUGH
THE WORLD'S LARGEST STRONG
ASSOCIATION WITH THE LIKES OF
AMAZON EIGHTEEN T. AND DJ I AS
WELL AS OTHERS AS MEMBERS.
AND WE HAD OPPOSE LESS AMENDED
POSITION BUT WE'RE HAPPY TO BE
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL NOW
THAT THE AUTHORS ACCEPTED THE
AMENDMENTS REFLECTED ME ANALYSIS
FOR PART ONE OF SEVEN EXEMPTION --
WE APPRECIATE THE CHAIRS PAST
WORK ON THIS ISSUE COMMITTEE
STAFF AND DRIVE FOR THE BILL.
THANKS VERY MUCH ADDITIONAL ON
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
PLEASE STEP FORWARD.
SCENE NINE OPPOSITION.
LIKE TO INVITE YOU TO COME ON UP
BY A I DON'T SEE ANY.
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
OKAY MISTER OBERNOLTE GO AHEAD
PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR --
APPRECIATE THE OTHER BRING THIS
FORWARD I THINK IT ADDRESSES AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE SO THE
AMENDMENTS ARE GONNA EXEMPT
ANYONE OPERATING UNDER.
F. A. R..
ONE OH SEVEN SO I'M WONDERING --
WHO?
WHAT OPERATOR WITH THIS APPLY TO
ANOTHER WAS WHAT WHAT CLASS OF
OPERATORS THERE THAT IS NOT
OPERATING UNDER IF WE ARE ONE OF?
SEVEN YEAH THE AMATEUR -- DRONE
OPERATORS THEY'RE NOT THEY'RE
NOT REQUIRED TO OPERATE UNDER
[inaudible]
ONE OH SEVEN NO [inaudible]
YEAH.
SO YOU HAVE TO FOR FAA ONE OH
SEVEN YOU HAVE TO MEET CERTAIN
REQUIREMENTS LIKE TRAINING.
ON AND I'VE ACTUALLY -- I'VE
ACTUALLY -- ATTENDED A CLASS AT
FULLER ST COLLEGE WHERE THEY ARE
TRAINING A DRONE OPERATORS AND
IN ORDER TO GET THAT YOU NEED --
TO IN ORDER TO BE CERTIFIED YOU
HAVE -- TO GO THROUGH IN A CLASS
AND THEN.
APPLY FOR THE FAA --
CERTIFICATION RIGHT AND FOR
UNDER ONE ONE SEVEN OPERATORS IF
THEY HAVE AN ACCIDENT THERE
WOULD HAVE -- TO NOTIFY TO THE
FAA WAS OUR UNDERSTAND
ACCIDENTALLY BUT I HAD THOUGHT
I'M NOT AN EXPERT ON ONE OF
SEVEN I'M AN EXPERT ON NINETY
ONE AND ONE THIRTY FIVE AND I
WANT -- TO SEVEN I HAD THOUGHT
THAT BECAUSE OF JUST READING
FROM ONE OH SEVEN DOT TWELVE IT
SAYS.
NO PERSON MAY MANIPULATE THE
FLIGHT CONTROLS OF A SMALL.
UNMANNED AIRCRAFT SYSTEM UNLESS
AND THEN THERE'S A WHOLE THING
OF OF OF CATEGORIES SO I THOUGHT
THAT EVEN RECREATIONAL.
DRONE OPERATORS HAD TO COMPLY
WITH ONE OF SEVEN BECAUSE ONE OF
SEVEN IS WHERE IT SAYS YOU HAVE
TO REGISTER GROWN YOU HAVE TO
GET A DRONE OPERATOR'S LICENSE.
AND SO THAT LEFT ME WONDERING
YOU KNOW IF WE'RE EXEMPTING ALL
OF ONE OF SEVEN PEOPLE OPERATING
UNDER WATER SEVEN WHO.
WHO'S LEFT.
SO AGAINST MY UNDERSTANDING THAT --
MOST COMMERCIAL OPERATORS ARE
PART ONE OF SEVEN AND THEN SOME
RECREATIONAL CAN CHOOSE TO GO
THROUGH THE FULL PART ONE OF
SEVEN PROCESS BUT WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO CAPTURE THOSE
RECREATIONAL OPERATORS WHO
AREN'T.
PART WHEN A SEVEN TO PROBABLY
THE FOLKS WHO ARE DOING THE
DAMAGE AT THE TEMPLE HER JUST
OKAY WELL WE'RE WE'RE GOING TO
JUDICIARY ACTS AS A RIGHT.
AFTER THIS.
WITH THIS BILL.
IT'S GOING TO TRANSPORTATION.
FLOOR BUT ALTHOUGH DELIVER MORE
RESEARCH ON THAT IF I COULD
OFFER ONE SUGGESTION -- IT WOULD
BE THAT YOU DEFINE DAMAGE A
LITTLE BIT MORE CLOSELY SO
YOU'RE REQUIRED TO TO FILE
REPORTER OR LEADER
IDENTIFICATION IF YOU'RE GROWN
CAUSES DAMAGE.
BUT TO TO JUST USE A RIDICULOUS
EXAMPLE IF YOU'RE FLYING A DRONE
AND YOU RUN OUT OF BATTERY AND
IT COMES DOWN IN SOMEONE'S YARD
INTO BANDS A SINGLE BLADE OF
GRASS I MEAN I'M I'M I'M BEING
RIDICULOUS HERE BUT I MEAN THAT
IS MATERIALLY DAMAGE RIGHT.
BUT THAT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT I
THINK THAT WERE INTENDING -- TO
SAY THAT THAT'S AN ACCIDENT A
REQUIRE YOU TO LEAVE NOTICE FOR
SO -- I WOULD SUGGEST THAT YOU
ADOPT THE SAME TEST THAT IF WE
ARE ONE OH SEVEN ADOPTION SAY
THAT THERE'S A FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLAR THRESHOLD.
YOU KNOW ABOVE WHICH THAT'S
CONSIDERED DAMAGE AND BELOW
WHICH IT'S NOT.
YEAH.
THAT'S SOMETHING DEFINITELY I'LL
LOOK INTO OKAY.
THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE OF YOU MAY CLOSE.
WITH THAT I'LL JUST.
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I AM
SOMEWHAT FAMILIAR WITH THE
LEGISLATION ALSO SO YES SO I I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR OF BRING
THIS BILL FORWARD ALSO.
SO WITH THAT THE RECOMMENDATION
IS -- TO PASS -- AS AMENDED TO
TRANSPORTATION SO MADE UP SIX
THREE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
I NEED A SECOND YES I DO HAVE A
SENSE OF MOTION BUT I NEED A
SECOND.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
[inaudible]
GO AHEAD.
HI SO I KILEY.
KILEY AYE BAUER QUE HAN.
RK HAND I BERMAN CALDERON.
GABRIEL GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I OR ONE WHEN I
OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE I'D SMITH.
SMITH I WEEKS [inaudible]
WHAT IS?
VOTES THE BILL IS OUT CONGRATS
THANK YOU SO MUCH [inaudible]
CELL [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
OKAY.
HELLO MISTER HERTZBERG HE IS
HERE.
YOU'RE JUST IN TIME.
IT DOESN'T TAKE TWO MINUTES ALL
RIGHT MISTER HERTZBERG HAS ITEM
TO SB.
THREE FORTY TWO PUBLIC.
YOU CAN CATCH YOUR BREATH MISTER
HERTZBERG.
IN DOING ITS YOU CAN ASK ME
QUESTIONS ALL FIGURED OUT.
DENNIS WELCOME CENTER HERTZBERG
[inaudible]
ARE YOU.
READING IS GERMAN YES I'M READY
I'M READY.
TO OKAY READY LET'S PROCEED.
THIS IS THE TICKET SCALPER
BUSINESS TRUTH AND TICKET
SCALPING.
WHAT HAPPENS IS A LOT OF FOLKS
OUT THERE ARE A?
TAKEN UP NAMES OF ROCK GROUPS --
SPORTS GROUPS OR WHATEVER PUT
THEM ON THE WEBSITE.
AND THERE THE THE THE AVERAGE
CONSUMER THINKS THAT THEY'RE
ACTUALLY BUYING A TICKET FROM
THAT ORGANIZATION AND THEY'RE
REALLY SCALPERS.
AND SO REALLY WHAT WE'RE DOING
IN THE SIMPLEST TERMS OF THIS
BILL WE GET DETAILS IS BASICALLY.
MAKE GET GIVEN A REMEDY AND STOP
IN THOSE PEOPLE BECAUSE THEY'RE
ENGAGING PHONY BALONEY BUSINESS --
AND THEY'RE THEY'RE RIPPING OFF
THE SYSTEM AND THEY'RE USING
DECEPTIVE PRACTICES TO DO SO --
THIS MODERN TECHNOLOGY OF THE
INTERNET THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DOING
HERE THAT'S WHAT WE'RE GIVEN IN
THE REMEDY.
AND UNLIKE OTHER CIRCUMSTANCES
LIKE WE'VE FACED HERE MISTER
CHAIRMAN PRIVACY ON THE PRIVATE
RIGHT OF ACTION THIS IS --
INDIVIDUALIZED BASIS FOR
FRAUDULENT BEHAVIOR THE NATURE
OF THE OF OF THE THE HARM
AGAINST THE REMEDY.
AND SO CLEARLY THAT IS EXACTLY
WE'RE GOING AFTER AND WITH THAT
OUTSIDE OF MY WITNESSES AND AS
FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FIRST WIN AS
PLEASE.
GAVIN CHAIRMAN CHAO MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS BRIAN
HESS I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF SPORTS FANS COALITION WHICH
IS THE NATION'S LEADING FAN
ADVOCACY GROUP.
TODAY I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF SB.
THIRTY THREE FORTY TWO FOR THE
LAST DECADE SPORTS FANS
COALITION IS FOUGHT FOR FANS WE
TACKLE ISSUE TO TO THE PUBLIC
FINANCING A SPORTS STADIUM
SPORTS BETTING CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS.
MEDIA ACCESS FOR LOW INCOME FANS
JP GENDER PAY EQUITY IN SUPPORT
AND TICKET FRAUD.
PASSING AS THREE FORTY TWO IN A
RICH SPORTS CULTURALLY
CALIFORNIANS WILL BE A MASSIVE
BLOW TO THE FRAUDSTERS YOU TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF FANS ESPECIALLY
LESS TECH SAVVY FANS.
BY USING MISLEADING MARKETING
TACTICS WHAT LABEL TICKET SITE
TO SEE FANS THAT THINK THEY'RE
BUYING DIRECTLY FROM VENUE BOX
OFFICE AT FACE VALUE BUT IN
REALITY ARE BUYING FROM A THIRD
PARTY.
PRETENDING TO BE THAT OFFICIAL
SITE.
I AM HERE ADVOCATING TO PROTECT
SPORTS FANS THIS FRAUD IMPACTS
ALL FANS OF LIVE EVENTS
INCLUDING CONCERTS AND THEATRE.
LABEL FRAUD WORKS LIKE THIS
CONSUMERS WILL USE GOOGLE OR
ANOTHER SEARCH ENGINE FOR
TICKETS TO AN INVENTOR VENUE.
AND MANY SITES WILL BE DISPLAYED --
BUT DESPITE NOT BEING LICENSED
OR OFFICIAL BOB MANY OF THE
SITES WE USE WORDS OFFICIAL OR
BOX OFFICE IN RELATION TO THE
VENUE.
AND UNDER THE BELIEF THE
CONSUMER IS ON THE REAL SICK AT
SITE THEY WILL PURCHASE A TICKET.
AFTER COMPLETING SEVERAL STEPS
IN THE CHECKOUT PROCESS THIS
CONSUMER IS HIT WITH SEVERAL
ADDITIONAL FEES WHICH CAN
SIGNIFICANTLY RAISE THE COST.
IN JULY OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN SPORTS RIMS COALITION
BEGAN INVESTIGATING THIS
PRACTICE WHAT WE DISCOVERED WAS
FAR MORE RAMPANT FRAUD WE HAD
INITIALLY BELIEVED.
EVERY RECENTLY REPLICATED THE
STUDY AND DESPITE MANY ATTEMPTS
BY INDUSTRY THE DECEPTIVE
WEBSITES CONTINUE TO PLAGUE
SEARCH ENGINES.
THE DANGERS OF THIS PRACTICE GO
WELL BEYOND JUST FOOLING FANS
AND THE CLICKING ON THEIR SITE
THERE ARE MAJOR FINANCIAL
IMPLICATIONS AS WELL. FOR
EXAMPLE RESELLERS WHO USE VIVID
SEATS OR TICKET NETWORKS WHITE
LABEL PLATFORMS FOR THE DECEMBER
SIXTEEN RAM VERSUS EAGLES GAME
LAST SEASON. TO SEE FANS IN THE
PURCHASING TICKETS FOR HUNDREDS
OF DOLLARS MORE THAN FACE VALUE.
IN SOME CASES BY CHARGING
SERVICE FEES EQUAL TO ONE THIRD
THE DISPLAYED PRICE.
SPORTS FANS COALITION BELIEVES
THE USE DECEPTIVE U. R. L.
SHOULD BE BANNED.
ON THE CUSP OF CALIFORNIA'S
TWENTY NINETEEN FOOTBALL SEASON
WITH THE RAMS TAKE IT BECOMING A
HOT COMMODITY AFTER THEIR
AMAZING SEVERAL RUN LAST YEAR.
AND THE RAIDERS PLAYING WHAT
MAYBE THEIR FINAL SEASON IN
OAKLAND THE POTENTIAL FOR WHITE
LABEL FRAUD IS GREATER THAN EVER.
AS SUCH SPORTSMAN COALITION
BECAUSE IN THE SENATORS --
SUPPORT SB THREE FORTY TWO AND
PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S FANS FROM
BEING DECEIVED THANK YOU.
THANKS MUCH -- ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
LOVE REPRESENTING EBAY SUB POP
ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU MUCH
NO NEXT PLEASE.
MARK PRAYER ON BEHALF OF AJ
OWNERS AND OPERATORS OF STAPLES
CENTER AND MULTIPLE OTHER VENUES
WE ARE DRIVE OUT.
THANK YOU MUCH NEXT PLEASE.
JOE RIGHT OUT WITH CONSUMER
ACTION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
MATCHA OPPOSITION PLEASE COME
FORWARD.
CENA AND UP BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
MR OBERNOLTE HAVE QUESTION
COMMON.
CENTER VERY SUPPORTIVE OF WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO HERE -- HAD
A COUPLE QUESTIONS FOR YOU THE
OUR FRAUDULENT PRACTICES THAT
ARE CURRENTLY BEING -- BEING
EXPERIENCED IN THIS DOMAIN.
WOULDN'T SOMEONE ALREADY BE ABLE --
TO TO SEE ONE OF THE UNFAIR
COMPETITION LAW THE FALSE
ADVERTISING LAW TO PUT A STOP TO
THESE TO THIS.
THEY WERE GIVEN A PRIVATE RIGHT
OF ACTION SEVENTY TWO HUNDRED IS
THE IS THE ACTION OF THE
BUSINESS PROFESSIONS GOD.
YES CERTAINLY THEY WOULD BUT I
THINK THAT JUST LIKE COM WHAT WE
DO WITH RANSOMWARE WE'VE DONE IN
THE COLD IS.
TOO YOU KNOW AS THE LAW CHANGES
OVER THE YEARS ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE FACED IS TO
MODERNIZE YOU KNOW WE DID WHAT
SIGNATURES TO ELECTRONIC
SIGNATURES WE'RE TRYING TO
CREATE A COLD THIS MORE
RESPONSIVE.
AND ALSO TO CREATE THE THE
DEPARTMENT OF ACTION IT QUITE
FRANKLY AND THEN INCLUDING GET
INJUNCTIVE RELIEF ALREADY UNDER
EVENTEEN TO WATER AND KNOW THAT
THAN SOME OF THOSE CASES IN MY
DAY.
BUT SO THAT WAS THE THAT'S THE
UNDERLYING THINKING BEHIND A
BEHIND THIS LEGISLATION OKAY SO
WHAT I HEARD YOU SAY WAS THAT
YES SOMEONE COULD BRING SUIT.
BUT THERE'S NO PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION UNDER THOSE STATUTES AND
THAT'S WHY THIS THIS
ACCOMPLISHES SOMETHING MORE.
RIGHT OKAY AND YOU DON'T LOSE
YOUR IT IT IF YOU LOOK AT THE
OTHER STATES HAVE BIG.
ABOUT SPORTS PERSON BUT I AM
TOLD THAT SO I CAN ABOUT A BIG
SPORTS BETTING NEW YORK NEW
JERSEY OTHER STATES THEY'VE DONE
THIS KINDA LAW.
AND WE'RE TRYING TO CUT
HARMONIZES AROUND THE STATUS
CALIFORNIA LOVES TO BE THE
LEADER AND EVERYTHING THIS IS
ONE WHERE WE'RE ACTUALLY --
TAKING THESE OTHER STATES THAT
HAVE PRETTY SIGNIFICANT
POSITIONS IN THIS AREA AND TRY
TO FOLLOW IT AND CONFORM LAW
OKAY.
AND CAN YOU TALK ABOUT WHY
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION WAS
NECESSARY BECAUSE THAT'S THE ONE
PART OF THE BILL TO GIVE ME A
LITTLE PAUSE YEAH I'D LIKE. TO
YEAH IT WAS IT GAVE ME SOME
PAUSE AS TO WHETHER OR NOT I
WANTED TO DO IS THIS -- EVEN
THOUGH BECAUSE I WE HAD THIS ON
PRIVACY HERE AT THIS COMMITTEE
HAD TO DEAL WITH.
AS SOME OF US NOW.
AND SO BUT IT'S DIFFERENT IT'S
DIFFERENT BECAUSE THIS
FRAUDULENT BEHAVIOR RIGHT.
PRIVATE ACTION OTHER INSTANCES
ARE WHETHER OR NOT SOMEBODY IS
WE WILL BE SEEN BEFORE LIKE IN
THE PARKING SPACES WERE SOMEBODY
AND PAINT THE THING EXACTLY THE
RIGHT WAY.
AND WHETHER THEY WOULD BE HELD
LIABLE AND THE IMPACT THAT WOULD
HAVE THIS STUFF WHEN WHICH YOU
JUST HEARD THE TESTIMONY.
I'M OUT THERE REPRESENTING THAT
THIS IS AN OFFICIAL NFL WHATEVER
THIS TEAM OR WHATEVER TEAM
DODGERS TEAM AND YOU COULD BUY
YOUR TICKETS HERE.
THIS IS AN ABSOLUTE DIRECT.
INTENTIONAL ACT TO DEFRAUD
PEOPLE ON THE INTERNET TO ME
LEVEL OF CULPABILITY IF YOU LOOK
AT OUR JURISPRUDENTIAL HISTORY
INFORMS CONSEQUENCES SO I'M
WILLING TO GO THERE BECAUSE THE
NATURE OF THE ACT BY ITS VERY --
BUT INFORMED ON ITS FACE IS
FRAUDULENT.
THAT TO ME IS WHAT MAKES THE
DISTINCTION THAT'S WHY I WENT
THERE BECAUSE I'M YOU KNOW
HESITANT WE HAVE DONE THIS VERY
OFTEN THE LAST. TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY YEARS AND I I BUT I THINK
IN THIS CASE BECAUSE OF THE
NATURE OF THE ACT IT'S THE
APPROPRIATE RESPONSE RIGHT THANK
YOU.
SURE.
pDO YOU THINK THAT I WANT TO
MENTION IS ESSENTIALLY THIS BILL
UPS THE ANTE OF FOR EXAMPLE
EXISTING LAW DOES NOT PROVIDE
FOR PUNITIVE DAMAGES.
OR ALL CONSEQUENTIAL DAMAGES
WHICH THIS BILL PROVIDES FOR IS
AS I'M NOT A CORRECT.
SO.
SO THE THE ON THE GO YOU KNOW I
HAVE A QUESTION YOU MAY OR MAY
NOT HAVE THE ANSWER BUT UP.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE ASSIGNMENT
OF THESE DOMAIN NAMES ARE YOU
ARE ELVES?
DO YOU KNOW HOW.
SEVERE THE PROBLEM IS IN THAT
YOU KNOW HOW MANY OF THESE
DOMAINS ARE YOU ARE YOU ARE
ELVES HAVE BEEN ASSIGNED TO
LET'S SEE COMPANIES THAT REALLY
DO NOT.
HAVE NO LEGITIMATE RIGHT CITIES
DOMAINS WE ARE EL IF YOU HAVE IF
YOU KNOW THE ANSWER I CAN ANSWER
THAT -- SO THERE'S THERE'S
REALLY ONLY TWO MAJOR NETWORK
COMP FORM COMPANIES THAT
FACILITATE IS WHITE LABELS IS
TAKING OUR CAN VIVID -- TAKEN
HOURS CURRENTLY UNDER A CONSENT
DECREE WITH THE DOJ FOR THIS
VERY BEHAVIOR -- THEY ALLOW
INDIVIDUAL RESELLERS LIKE ANYONE
IN THIS ROOM CAN GO AND CREATE A
U. R. L. ONCE THEY BY THE DOMAIN
NAME.
AND THEN USE THE BACK AND
TECHNOLOGY THE PLATFORM ABOVE
AND TO TAKE AN HOUR TO ACTUALLY
SELL.
USE THAT WAY NO ONE HAS TO BE A
YOU KNOW A CODER THINK OF IF
YOU'RE BUILDING A WEBSITE ON
SQUARE SPACE.
YEAH YOU DON'T HAVE TO CO THE
WEBSITE USED.
PAULA PLATFORM UP -- BUT SO WHAT
ENDS UP HAPPENING IS A BY THESE
THIS UP TO YOU NO MEANS GIVEN
TAKE NOW WE DON'T REALLY.
REVIEW THOSE AT ALL OR THEY THEY
SOMETIMES WILL CLAIM LIKE THEY
HAVE COMMUNITY STANDARDS BUT WE
DON'T SEE ANY ENFORCEMENT SO
IT'S IN THE STUDY I REFERENCE IN
TWO THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN WHEN
I GOOGLED WRIGLEY FIELD TICKETS.
WE CAME BACK WITH FOUR OUT OF
FIVE OF THE TOP -- PAID SEARCH
RESULTS.
ADS WERE RIGHT LABEL SITES THAT
SAID THINGS LIKE RIDLEY TICKET
STOP BOX OFFICE DOT COM --
BEYOND THAT WHEN WE WENT DOWN TO
THE ORGANIC RESULTS FIVE OF THE
TOP FIVE ON THE FIRST PAGE OF
GOOGLE WERE THESE WHITE LABEL
COMPANIES.
PRETENDING AND YOU HAD TO GO TO
THE VERY BOTTOM ACTUALLY FIND.
RIDLEY TICKETS NOW GOOGLE HAS
DONE A LOT OF WORK IN THIS SPACE.
TO CUT CARVE THIS BEHAVIOR --
OTHER SEARCH ENGINES HAVE NOT --
AND SO YOU YOU GET VARYING
RESULTS DEPENDING ON WHICH
SEARCH ENGINE YOU PREFER
[inaudible]
GOT IT.
MISS KILEY GUY.
SO I THINK THIS IS A GOOD STEP
I'M I'M WONDERING.
YOU KNOW HOW OFTEN PEOPLE REALLY
LOOK AT THE AT THE ACTUAL YOU
ARE OUT WHEN THEY CLICK ON A
SEARCHES HONOR THESE COMPANIES
USING OTHER.
TACTICS LIKE PARROTING THE
APPEARANCE OF THE OFFICIAL SITE
AND YEAH IT WAS A WAY WE CAN GET
A THAT CONDUCT YEAH SO THE TITLE
OF THE WEB PAGE THE THING THAT
MOST PEOPLE YOU KNOW READ
BECAUSE YOU'RE RIGHT.
I DON'T READ THE U. R. L. OF
EVERY YOUR SEARCH ENGINE RESULTS.
THE TOP HEADLINE IS OFTEN TIMES
JUST.
SACRAMENTO KINGS TICKETS. TWENTY
OF TWENTY NINETEEN SEASON -- OR
THINGS LIKE THAT WHERE IT'S YOU
JUST CLICK IT AND YOU DON'T
THINK ESPECIALLY IF.
YOU -- YOUR VISIONS A PAIR YOU
CAN'T READ THE SMALL PRINT IN
THE U. R. L. YOU CAN'T TELL THE
TO ADD OR NOT -- WE'VE SEEN
THESE KINDS OF THINGS HEART
OFFICIALLY -- OLDER FOR OLDER
FANS LIKE PEOPLE TRYING TO BUY
TICKETS -- FOR THEIR GRANDKIDS
AS GIFTS.
THEY'LL USE THOUGH YOU JUST LIKE
SACRAMENTO KINGS TICKETS IN THE
TOP.
BUT THAT THIS BILL WOULDN'T STOP
THEM FROM DOING THAT -- WHAT IT
YEAH BECAUSE THEY WILL BE STILL
USING OFFICIAL -- AND THAT
WOULDN'T BE IN THE U. R. L. SO
THAT WOULD DEFINITELY BE COVERED
BY THE BILL RIGHT.
I HAVE THE DIFF -- FOR THE
SENATE BECAUSE THOSE REMAINS
WITH THOSE QUESTIONS RIGHT I
DON'T KNOW WHAT SO HE WAS GIVEN
AN EXAMPLE OF WHERE -- YOU KNOW
MAYBE ON THAT WEB PAGE ITSELF
THE KIND OF MAKE IT LOOK LIKE
IT'S THE OFFICIAL -- DISTRIBUTOR --
BAD YOU KNOW AND THAT'S KIND OF
WHAT'S MORE LIKELY TO CATCH
SOMEONE'S EYE AS OPPOSED TO
LOOKING AT THAT THE OR ELSE IT
IS THE BILL PROVIDE A WAY TO
YEAH TALK RIGHT NOW THAT MONEY
TO TALKS ABOUT THE CREATING
DECEPTIVE PRACTICES IN TERMS OF
LIKE IF YOU WANT. TO GO FOR THE
DAY.
SORRY FOR THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA TO THE DODGERS FOR
EXAMPLE [inaudible]
THE DODGERS.
MR GABRIEL THE DODGERS THANK YOU.
AND SO YOU KNOW THEY'LL HAVE IT
LOOK IT WILL JUST SAY IT WHEN
YOU CLICK ON IT LOOK LIKE IT'S A
DODGER SITE IT'S DECEPTIVE THE
IDEA WHEN YOU READ THE BILL.
TALKS ABOUT DECEPTIVE TO BE ABLE
TO MISINFORM THE VIEWER THAT
THIS IS IN THE FACT THAT THE AIR
FASHION OFFICIAL UNOFFICIAL SITE
SO IT'S DEEPER THAN JUST THE U.
R. L. IT'S ACTUALLY THE LARGER
DECEPTIVE PRACTICES IN ORDER TO
TRY.
TO BASICALLY FOR A JEEP PEOPLE
TO BELIEVE THAT THEY'RE ACTUALLY
BUYING TICKETS FROM THE DOCTORS.
ONE AND IT TALKS ABOUT USING
THEIR TRADEMARKS TO A TRADEMARK
OR NAME SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR
I'M READING FROM PAGE THREE OF
THE MEASURE. TO THOSE REFERRED
TO IN THE SUBDIVISION INCLUDING
THAT LIMIT TO MISSPELLING OF A
TRADE MARK OR TRADE NAME
REFERRED TO ON IF YOU SEEN THIS
BEFORE BUT SOMEONE LIKE TAKE A
LETTER OUT MAKE IT LOOK LIKE.
SOMETHING IN THIS SPELL IT IN
ORDER TO GET A DIFFERENT NAME
BUT IT LOOKS LIKE WHEN YOU'RE
QUICKLY LOOKING AT IT EXACTLY
THE TRADE NAME YOU'RE LOOKING
AFTER AND YOU MARRY THAT WITH
THE RIGHT COLORS IN THE TRADE
WHEN THEY THAT YOU DID THE
LOGO'S AND STUFF.
YOU'RE YOU'RE YOU'RE DECEIVING
PEOPLE AND THAT'S REALLY WHAT
WE'RE GETTING TO THE I THINK
WEARING THOSE IT ONLY APPLIES IF
IT'S IN THE U. R. L. ITSELF
RIGHT [inaudible]
RIGHT.
I THINK THAT THAT ONLY APPLIES
THE WAY I'M READING THE LANGUAGE
OF ITS IN THE U. R. L. ITSELF
[inaudible]
WHAT [inaudible]
YEAH.
THAT'S HOW THEY DO THAT'S HOW
THEY GET YEAH.
I'VE HAD OVER YOU'VE HAD IT
HAPPENED MAYBE HAVING YOUR
POLITICAL CAMPAIGNS WHERE PEOPLE
MAKE ONE DIFFERENT AND LETTER
AND STUFF IN THE BIG CRATE FOR
WEBSITES I'VE HAD IT HAPPEN TO
ME AND NUMBER OF ELECTIONS
OFFICES IS APPLIED ELECTIONS.
BUT YOU SEE ALL THE TIME OR LAW
OFTEN WHEN PEOPLE WANT TO GET
YOU TO CLICK ON THINGS.
TO YOUR CREDIT CARD COMPANIES
WHATEVER THEY'LL DO THIS TO THE
END OF A IMPLANT A A BUGGY I
MEAN THAT BUT WHAT THEY CALL A
VIRUS IN YOUR SYSTEM.
THAT REALLY IS THE WAY THAT THEY
GET TO YOU.
YEAH I THINK IT'S AS WELL I'M
HAPPY VERY HAPPY TO SUPPORTED --
BUT DIED THE IT DOES SEEM LIKE
THERE'S STILL GONNA BE SOME WAYS
AROUND IT SO IT'S A IT'S A GOOD
QUESTION IS ALSO -- SOME OTHER
WORKING AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL THE
BOSS ACT THAT WOULD BE
ADDRESSING -- EVEN DEEPER THAN
JUST YOUR HOUSE BUT BROADLY
USING THE WITH THE WEBSITE
ITSELF.
MR GABRIEL GUY GREAT BILL GO
DODGERS SECOND ALL.
YEAH THE POWER.
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED -- AND THE
RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASS TO
JUDICIARY SENATOR WHICH LIKE TO
CLOSE ASPEN ABOUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF A MAN SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
OUT HI NOW I KILEY KILEY AYE
BARKING AND BARKING AND I BERMAN.
BERMAN HI CALDERON [inaudible]
HI GABRIEL -- I GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I IRWIN -- WHEN I
OBERNOLTE?
OBERNOLTE AYE SMITH SMITH I
WICKS.
WICKS ON ITS UNANIMOUS AGAIN
GRADUATION ELEVEN IS THERE A HA.
THANK YOU SENATOR I SEE SENATOR
HUESO E
ONE BILL TO PRESENT AND THAT IS
ITEM NUMBER ONE SB TWO OH EIGHT
DONE.
ANYTIME YOU'RE READY YOU MAY
PRESENT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS -- I'M HERE PERCENT SB
TO AWAIT THIS IS A CONSUMER
PROTECTION BILL AND AIMED AT
PREVENTING ROBO CALL SCAMS.
REBEL CALL SCAMS ARE THE NUMBER
ONE COMPLAINT IN THE NATION.
ACCORDING TO THE FEDERAL TRADE
COMMISSION FRAUD GENERATES THE
GREATEST NUMBER OF COMPLAINTS TO
THE COMMISSION.
AND 70% OF THE SCAMS START OVER
THE TELEPHONE.
SPOOFING AS IT'S KNOWN --
ESPECIALLY NEIGHBOR SPOOFING IT
IS KEY TO MAKING THESE SCAMS
WORK.
THE VOLUME OF SPOOFED CALLS IS
INCREASING EXPERTS ESTIMATE THAT
BY. 202040% OF ALL CALLS MADE IN
ON YOUR TELEPHONE ON OUR
TELEPHONE ON THE PEOPLE OF
AMERICA'S TELEPHONES.
WILL BE SPOOFING CALLS THESE
WOULD BE.
CALLS ARE INTENDED TO DEFRAUD
PEOPLE OF THEIR MONEY.
AND THEY ARE INTENDED.
REALLY TO FIND -- PEOPLE THAT
THAT THEY CAN SCAMMON THIS IS
USUALLY THE ELDERLY THIS IS
USUALLY THE PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES THIS IS USUALLY
YOUNG PEOPLE WHOEVER THEY CAN
FIND -- WITH MONEY THEIR THEIR
OBD OBJECTIVE IS TO STEAL
PEOPLE'S MONEY NINE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS WAS TAKEN FROM
CONSUMERS LAST YEAR THIS BILL
SETS SO JULY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
DEADLINE FOR THE
TELECOMMUNICATION PROVIDERS. TO
IMPLEMENT CALLER AUTHENTICATION
MEMBER MEASURES WHICH CAN HELP
IDENTIFY ILLEGAL WROBEL CALLS
AND PREVENT CONSUMERS FROM BEING
SCAMMED I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY.
THANKS MY CHECK OFFICE WHEN HIS
PLACE.
HI TERRY DAIS SANDERS
REPRESENTING THE OFFICE REPAIR
ADVOCATES -- MEMBERS -- THING IS
INCREASINGLY EMPLOYED BY BAD
ACTORS WHO DESCRIBES OUR
IDENTITY TO MAKE IT MORE LIKELY
THAT THE CALL PERSON WILL PICK
UP THE PHONE.
AND POTENTIALLY FALL FOR THEIR
SCAM.
ON THIS BILL SIMPLY REQUIRES
TELEKINETIC TELECOMMUNICATION
PROVIDERS TO IMPLEMENT EXISTING
TELL TECHNOLOGIES TO VERIFY A
CALLER'S IDENTITY -- WE SUPPORT
THIS BILL BECAUSE IT WILL HELP
PROTECT CONSUMERS FROM SCAMS
DECEPTIVE MARKETING PRACTICES OR
OTHER ILLEGAL ACTIVITIES I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST RIGHT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MUCH ANNEX WHEN HIS
PLACE GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRMAN VERSE OF NAS YOUR
HERNANDEZ HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
UTILITY REFORM NETWORK.
AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
AS THE AUTHOR INDICATED THIS IS
NOT ONLY A PROBLEM BUT A GROWING
PROBLEM ON THAT HAVE FACTS --
MANY PEOPLE THAT WE KNOW -- MANY
OF US AS WELL.
I HAVE RECEIVED THESE CALLS ON
THEIR OWN GOING IN FACT -- JUST
TODAY.
EARLIER TODAY THE F. T. C.
ANNOUNCED SOME ACTIONS THAT IT'S
TAKING AGAIN SOME COMPANIES FOR
THESE ROBO CALLS IDENTIFIED A
SINGLE COMPANY FOR BEING
RESPONSIBLE FOR I BELIEVE IT WAS
FIFTY SIX MILLION CALLS -- OVER
A SIX MONTH PERIOD -- IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN SO THE NUMBERS ARE
STAGGERING THE NUMBERS ARE
GROWING THE NUMBERS ARE.
REALLY PROBLEMATIC AND REALLY
THE KEY THING ABOUT THIS BILL
THAT SETS A TIME CERTAIN -- WHEN
THE INDUSTRY MUST ADOPT AND AND --
UTILIZE A SOFTWARE THERE AND
TECHNOLOGY THAT IS IN PLACE THAT
WILL HELP ADDRESS THIS ISSUE.
OF THE INDUSTRY'S ALREADY
WORKING ON THIS THEY ARE --
PRIME -- TO IMPLEMENT AND
UTILIZE THIS TECHNOLOGY FOR THE
FEDS -- THIS JUST GIVES A TIME
CERTAIN AND SOME COMFORT IN
CALIFORNIA CONFERENCE THE
CALIFORNIA THAT IT WILL BE USED
AND WE KNOW WHEN IT WILL BE USED.
SO WE CAN ADDRESS THAT I'LL JUST
MENTION ON THE SITE ON A
PERSONAL NOTE I TESTIFIED ON
THIS BILLS FOR THIS BILL LAST
WEEK -- IN THE NEXT DAY -- THE
NEXT MORNING I RECEIVED BACK TO
BACK TO BACK TO BACK CALLS
RUBBLE CALLS -- SAYING THAT I
NEEDED -- TO YOU KNOW CALL THIS
NUMBER BACK AND PAY -- EX NUMBER
OF DOLLARS -- TO THE COMPANY SO
I IMAGINE THAT TOMORROW I'M
GONNA END UP WITH MORE CALLS AND
SOME HERE TESTIFYING AGAINST
POOR BUT I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
AND I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR --
FOR FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ADDITIONAL
SUPPORTERS PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELF AND YOUR MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS JAMES JACK
HERE ON BEHALF OF CAL TELL AS
TELCO CARRIERS OURSELVES WE ARE
PLEASED -- TO HAVE BEEN
SUPPORTIVE OF SENATOR PLACES
BILL SINCE ITS INTRODUCTION --
APPRECIATE HIS COMMITMENT TO
TAKE SOME CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS
WHEN IT GETS TWO PROBES AND LOOK
FORWARD OFFERING OUR FULL
SUPPORT AT THAT TIME THANK YOU
THANK YOU MUCH NEXT PLEASE.
SEEING NO OTHER SUPPORTERS SO
OPPOSITION PLEASE -- COMPORT.
IF YOU CAN MAKE SOME ROOM FOR
OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
FIRST PARTY A ROSTER WITH
CALIFORNIA CABLE AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION --
WE ARE OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED BUT
LET ME CLARIFY VERY CLEARLY WE
ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THE EFFORTS OF
OF ADOPTING THIS TECHNOLOGY TO
BLOCK THESE ROLL CALLS -- THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT THE FCC HAS
ALREADY REQUIRED US TO DO AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL -- WE ALSO HAVE
TWO PENDING FEDERAL PIECES OF
LEGISLATION AND ONE OF THEM WILL
MANDATE THAT WE ADOPT THAT
TECHNOLOGY.
SO THAT IS NOT PROBLEMATIC FOR
US -- WE HAVE A VERY SMALL
LITTLE ISSUE HERE WITH THE
PROPOSAL -- THE BILL CALLS OUT
SECTION TWO TWO SEVEN OF TITLE
FORTY SEVEN OF THE FEDERAL
STATUTES AND IN THAT CODE
SECTION THAT'S THE CODE SECTION
THAT GIVES THE STATE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S THE AUTHORITY TO
ENFORCE.
ALL THE MISUSE OF COMMUNICATION
DEVICES SO RUBBLE CALLS BEING
ONE OF THEM -- THAT STATUE ALSO
IN THE ANNOUNCES APPROPRIATE
CALLS OUT THAT THEY CAN THE
STATE'S CAN ALSO DESIGNATE AN
ADDITIONAL STATE AGENCY TO HELP
IN THAT ENFORCEMENT THIS BILL
CALLS OUT THE P. YOU SEE.
OUR CONCERNS WITH THAT PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION. TO THE
EXTENT THAT THE PROPOSAL DOES
NOT GRANT ANY NEW ADDITIONAL
AUTHORITY TO THE PC IN A
REGULATORY FASHION -- WE'RE NOT
OPPOSED TO THAT -- BUT IF THE
PROPOSAL THAT THE LANGUAGE IS
VERY BROAD IN THIS AND THERE'S
NO BUMPERS AROUND IT SO WHAT WE
SEE IS SORT OF REPERTORY TREAT.
AND THAT'S OUR THAT'S OUR MAIN
CONCERN -- BUT TO THE ISSUE OF
RUBBLE COSTS WITH THIS THAT I WE
STIPULATE EVERYTHING THE SENATOR
SAID THEY ARE THE WORST
OFFENDERS OUT THERE AND JUST
TODAY THE FTC ON OUR WEBSITE
ANNOUNCED I WISH HAD THIS
INFORMATION YESTERDAY TO SHARE
WITH EVERYONE.
ANNOUNCED THE CALL IT QUITS
OPERATION CALL IT QUITS AND
THEY'VE TAKEN NINETY FOUR MAJOR
ACTIONS AGAINST BAD RUBBLE
CALLERS -- IN CALIFORNIA ALONE --
THE COUNTIES OF LOS ANGELES --
RIVERSIDE SAN DIEGO AND SANTA
CLARA -- TOOK ACTIONS -- TODAY
TO GO AFTER SOME REALLY BAD
REBEL CALLERS SO WE'RE WE'RE
SUPPORTER OF THAT EFFORT SENATOR
AND SO WITH THAT I MEAN WE ARE
ONLY CONCERN IS SORT OF A RECORD
FOR A CREEP.
WITH THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION IF WE COULD PUT SOME
BUMPERS AROUND THAT TO CLARIFY
THAT THEIR ROLE IS PURELY -- AS
AN EXPERT IN.
IN ENFORCING UP CIVIL CASES AT
THE FEDERAL COURT BECAUSE OF
SECTION TWO TWO SEVEN IS AN
ENFORCEMENT PROVISION NOT
AGAINST COMMUNICATION SERVICE
PROVIDERS BUT AGAINST REBEL
CALLERS -- AND THAT LANGUAGE --
WOULD -- HELP IF YOU COULD IF
THE PC WAS TO HELP THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL PROSECUTE CASES THE
FEDERAL COURT WE WILL BE SUPPORT
OF THAT SO WITH THAT -- WAS NICE
BUT I WANT TO TAKE THE CENTER TO
WE'VE MADE WE'VE COME A LONG WAY
WE'VE HAD.
VERY GOOD DISCUSSIONS -- CENTER
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME -- WITH
US ON THIS I THINK WE'RE VERY
CLOSE TO SOME RESOLUTION BUT AT
THE MOMENT THE BILL IN PRINT WE
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED.
THANK YOU MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE MR AND MEMBERS --
JONATHAN HERE WILL BE HALF OF C.
T. I. AID THE TRADE ASSOCIATION
FOR THE WIRELESS INDUSTRY.
WE ALSO -- MUST OPPOSE SB TO
AWAIT THE THE FOUR NATIONAL
WIRELESS CARRIERS ARE ACTUALLY
ON TRACK TO IMPLEMENT -- STIR
SHAKE IN OUR PROGRAM TO COMBAT
UNWANTED WROBEL CALLS BY THE END
OF THE YEAR.
THE FCC ACTUALLY CONTINUE TO
TAKE SIGNIFICANT STEPS -- TO
COMBAT UNWANTED REBEL BECAUSE WE
ALSO BELIEVE THAT.
YOU KNOW THE CPC IS NOT EQUIPPED
TO ENFORCE.
LAWS DEALING WITH ROBO CALLS WE
THINK IT'S JUST THE WRONG AGENCY
BY INVOLVING THE C. P. U. C..
WE ACTUALLY THINK SB TWO AWAY
COULD DIVERT ATTENTION AND FOCUS
FROM IMPLEMENTING THE PROGRAMS
AND ADD A LAYER OF REGULATION
THAT IS.
YOU KNOW OFTEN DON'T SEE PC TIME
CONSUMING LENGTHY AND WE THINK
IN THIS CASE JUST UNNECESSARY --
IT'S ALSO WORTH NOTING THAT THE
FCC ON JUNE SIX THEY ADOPTED A
NOTICE OF PROPOSED RULEMAKING
THAT PROPOSES A MANDATE TO
IMPLEMENT THE SHAKEN STIR.
IF MAJOR VOICE SERVICE WRITERS
FAILED TO DO SO SO BY THE END OF
THIS YEAR -- AND YOU BECAUSE
THIS TO CREATE A PASSWORD OR
STATE LAWS INVOLVED IN CEBU
SEEING COMPLICATE THINGS -- THE
OF SEE IS ACTUALLY ENGAGE IN
FOCUS ON THIS ISSUE -- AND SO WE
YOU KNOW STILL MUST OPPOSE SB.
TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OPPOSITIONAL OPPOSITION PLEASE
COMPORT.
YOUR NAME IN ORGANIZATION PLACE
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS DOMINICK
TOMORROW HERE ON BEHALF OF
FRONTIER COMMUNICATIONS. FOR THE
REASONS PREVIOUSLY STATED
OPPOSED THANK YOU MUCH.
LET'S BRING BACK TO COMMITTEE
QUESTION MISTER CALDERON GO
AHEAD.
A CENTER OUT THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD I
THINK THERE'S A MEMBER.
ARE PICKED INDIVIDUAL THE
AUDIENCE RIGHT NOW THE HASN'T
RECEIVED A TON OF THESE CALLS
I'VE BEEN CALLED.
BY MYSELF AND I KNEW I WAS BEING
SPOOFED BUT I HAD ANSWERED JUST
BECAUSE I WAS CURIOUS.
WHAT I SOUNDED LIKE?
AND LIKE IT'S OUT OF MY OWN
VOICE BUT YOU KNOW IT'S FUNNY
WHEN YOU CALL ME AND I GET
FILTERS TO BUT I YOU KNOW I IT I
HAVE VERIZON AND ACTUAL WAS ABLE
TO DOWNLOAD AN APP I KNOW
EIGHTEEN T. HAS IT AS WELL --
WHERE EVERY TIME IT'S ONE OF
THESE IT'S NOT EVERY TIME BUT?
IT'S PRETTY GOOD A PICK AND
PICKING UP THE SPOOFING CALLS
AND SO IT'LL SAY POTENTIAL SPAM --
ON MY AB WHILE I'M CALLING AND I
JUST KIND OF DECLINE THE CALL IT
HAS BEEN REALLY HELPFUL FOR ME
TO BE ABLE.
TO KIND OF WE THESE CALLS OUT --
BUT AGAIN ALL TIME -- YOU KNOW I
I UNDERSTAND.
WHERE THEY OPPOSITION COMING
FROM IN TERMS OF CPU CME?
THE LEGISLATURE SPECIFICALLY OUR
HOUSES AND A LOT OF ISSUES WHEN
IT COMES TO THE CPUC -- BUT NONE
THE LESS I THINK THIS BILL IS
REALLY IMPORTANT TO MOVE FORWARD
BECAUSE OF THE ISSUE THAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH I MEAN MY ONLY
CONCERN WOULD JUST BE MAKING
SURE THAT.
WE DO CC ROBO CALLS WELL
MAYBE NOT AS MUCH ANYMORE BUT WE
HAVE DONE I HAVE -- FIFTY FAMILY
FRIEND THAT HAS YOU KNOW DOES
REBEL CALLS AND YOU KNOW MAKES A
MAKES A BUSINESS OUT OF IT SO I
WOULD WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE ARE THE PROPER PROTECTIONS
IN THERE FOR LEGITIMATE.
BUSINESS PRACTICES YOU KNOW THAT
THOSE CALLS THAT AREN'T JUST
DISPROVING CALLS MEANT TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF YOU -- AT THAT WERE
CAPTURING THOSE AND NOT ACTUALLY
TEARING DOWN LEGITIMATE
BUSINESSES WHERE PEOPLE ARE
MAKING GOOD WAGES AND MADE IT
OUT.
DOING YOU KNOW SOMETHING MORE
ALONG THE LINES OF WHAT WE FIND
ACCEPTABLE SUPPOSE THESE
SPOOFING CAUSE BUT I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION BECAUSE IT'S A
NIGHTMARE IT'S A NUISANCE.
WE GET THESE CALLS ALL THE TIME
I'M SICK OF IT AND FOR EVERYBODY
ELSE IS SICK OF IT BUT WE CAN'T
GET THEIR WHETHER HAVING THIS
DISCUSSION.
I THINK THAT THE STATE SHOULD
PLAY A ROLE IN AND HOW -- THESE
POLICIES -- GUARANTEE
IMPLEMENTED NOT JUST IN OUR
STATE BUT NATIONWIDE AS WELL SO
THANK YOU [inaudible]
MR BERMAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WAS
ADJOURNED AND CENTER THANK YOU
FOR BRING THIS BILL I'D I THINK
YOU KNOW WE ALL HERE AND
PROBABLY ALL OF OUR CONSTITUENTS
HAVE BEEN IMPACTED BY IT BY
SCOOPING CALLS AND JUST THE THE
PAIN.
THAT THE IN THE IN THE BEHIND
THEY CREATE -- COULD YOU SPEAK
TO A LITTLE I I ALSO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT THE CPC AND THEIR
ROLE IN THE BILL KEY TO SPEAK A
LITTLE BIT -- TO YOU KNOW WHY IS
IT NECESSARY TO HAVE A BE BOTH
AG AND THE CBC -- OR IS THERE
SOME ROOM THERE TO MAN MOVEMENT
ON THAT ISSUE AND IT THEY THEY
MENTION THAT THE BILL IS VERY
GENERAL AND THAT EFFORT AND
ACTUALLY THIS IS A VERY
EXTREMELY NARROW BILL.
THE BILL SIMPLY REQUIRESTHEM TO
IMPLEMENT.
A AUTHENTICATION PROGRAM
[inaudible]
AND THE NEXT THING.
WE HAVE TO ENFORCE THE LAW SO
HOW WOULD WE ACTUALLY ENFORCE
THAT THEY'RE FOLLOWING THROUGH
AND IMPLEMENTING.
THIS TECHNOLOGY WHO WOULD
OVERSEE THAT WHO WOULD.
ARE A CONFIRM THAT THEY ARE
NUMBER TWO WE WANT TO GO AFTER
THE THE THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
SCAMMING.
IF THERE WAS A WAY TO TRACK DOWN
WHO THESE PEOPLE ARE IF THERE
FOR SOME REASON.
LAW ENFORCEMENT ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE -- FINDS THAT --
THIS IS ACTUALLY HAPPENING.
THERE'S ALSO GOT TO BE A
MECHANISM TO ENFORCE THAT PART
OF IT SO THE PCS OF EXTREMELY
LIMITED ROLE.
I UNDERSTAND THEIR CONCERNS
ABOUT THE UC USING THIS BILL TO
PRY OPEN OTHER -- YOU KNOW OTHER
REGULATORY ACTION THAT WOULD NOT
BE -- ALLOWED UNDER THIS BILL.
IT WOULD NOT BE APPROPRIATE
ACTION AS DEFINED BY THE BILL --
I'M.
COMFORTABLE WITH WORKING WITH
THEM TO THE FURTHER DEFINED THAT
OR SUBMIT A LETTER TO THE
JOURNAL AND TO THAT REGARD.
BUT WE BELIEVE THAT WE NEED --
TO CONFIRM THAT THE
TELECOMMUNICATION COMPANIES ARE
DOING THIS AND THAT COULD COULD
BE THE P. UC'S ROLE AND ALSO TO
WORK WITH YOU TENER TOURNEY
GENERAL TO COMPILE DATA.
GETTING GET DATA TOGETHER DOES
NOT -- AND AND IT WOULD BE
SPECIFIC TO LOOK IN FOR THE
SCAMMERS AND IT WOULD BE
SPECIFIC -- TO WORKING WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL BEING PEOPLE --
TO JUSTICE.
I DON'T SEE FOR WE LIVE I'VE
DISCUSSED THIS WITH THEM AT
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF THE YEAR
WE'VE BEEN IN TALKS WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT HOW -- THERE THERE
MAY BE SOME CONCERNS -- OUT
PEOPLE WERE STILL AT THE TABLE.
I DON'T WANNA RAISE -- ANY
MISTER PROBLEMS FOR THEM BUT
WERE REALLY NARROWLY FOCUSED ON
ENSURING THAT.
THE PC DOES ITS JOB NOT SURE
THEY'RE DOING THAT AND WE GO AND
AND THIS PRACTICES STOPPED AS
MUCH AS WE CAN AND YOU KNOW PUT
IN.
BRINGING SOME PEOPLE THAT WHAT'S
RESOURCES TO FIND PUT AN END OF
THIS IS ME IS WHAT MAY BE
REQUIRED IN THIS PROCESS.
SO AS I READ IT THE FEDERAL RT
GRANTS AUTHORITIES HE PCM I READ
ABOUT THAT.
IT'S NOT JUST THE AG UNDER.
TWO TWO SEVEN BUT TO ANY
COMMISSION.
IN THIS ROOM AS WELL.
WELL THAT.
IS A SOMEWHAT COMPLICATED TO A
CERTAIN EXTENT IT IS -- YOUR
YOU'RE RIGHT AND I COULDN'T.
TELL TELL YOU THE LETTER OF THE
LAW ON THAT -- BUT UNDER THIS
UNDER THIS BILL -- IT REALLY
DOESN'T EVEN.
GO.
THAT ADDITIONAL STEP WE WE
DEFINE VERY VERY CLEARLY WHAT
THE CPUC ROLE WITHIN IN THIS
REGARD IT'S A VERY NARROW.
IT ONLY HAS TO DO WITH --
COMPILING DATA TO WORK WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE AND
ENSURE THAT THEY ARE COMPLYING
WITH THE STATE LAW IT'S VERY
NARROW.
YEAH I MEAN IT SAYS THAT
WHENEVER THE AG OF A STATE OR AN
OFFICIAL OR AGENCY DESIGNATED BY
THE STATE RIGHTS WE'VE
DESIGNATED THIS AGENCY.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN SI PC IN THIS
ROUND SO I WOULD AND AFTER THAT
I JUST YOU.
TWO SEVEN THEY HAVE THE STORY
AND I SHARE MY COLLEAGUES
CONCERNED I THINK THE CPC HAS
SOME PRETTY IMPORTANT JOBS TO DO
RIGHT NOW -- BUT BUT WITH REGARD
TO VOICE -- WHAT VOICE OVER
INTERNET?
THE THE LEGISLATURE SETS THE
POLICY ON ARE THE PC WAS TO GIVE
AND TAKE IN THE WAY THAT
RESPONSIBLY BUT BY THE BY THE
LEGISLATURE WITH.
WITH VOICE RULES.
AND AND SO THE NEW RULE IS
LEGISLATURE'S THAT SETS THE
POLICY THIS IS WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO AN ATTEMPT TO SET THE
POLICY AND WHERE THE PC.
HAS JURISDICTION OF COURSE I
UNDERSTAND.
THE THE TELECOMMUNICATION
COMPANIES KIND OF WORK VERY HARD
TO MAKE SURE YOU SEE IS NOT
INVOLVED IN SETTING UP POLICY
THAT WE ARE.
AND WHEN WE TRY WON'T BECAUSE
THIS IS WHAT IT YOU KNOW THIS IS
THE END PRODUCT.
AND I HAVE ONE OTHER QUESTION AM
MENTIONED -- SO I GET ROBO CALLS
FOR MY KIDS SCHOOL WHEN THERE'S
A LOCK DOWN FOR EXAMPLE THAT THE
RECALL I WANT TO GET.
SO HOW DOES THIS BILL HOW DO YOU
PROTECTING FROM THINGS LIKE THAT
THAT'S A LEGAL CALL COMING FROM
YOUR SCHOOL.
AND IT'S NOT SOMEBODY GENERATING
A FAKE CALL USING.
A FAKE ID -- USAIN -- COME OF
THE COMPUTER PROGRAM THAT'S
INTENDED TO HIDE THEIR
IDENTITIES SO.
THOSE CALLS -- THE THE THIS THIS
TECHNOLOGY.
OTHER SHAKEN ANSWERS IS IS
DESIGNED TO SPECIFICALLY.
WITHOUT THOSE CALLS AND AND IT
IF I WAS GIVE THIS EXAMPLE IT'S
NOT.
I MEAN IT'S IT'S FOR FOR YOU TO
UNDERSTAND KIND OF THE GENERAL
CONCEPT OF HOW.
THESE COMPUTER PROGRAMS ARE
DESIGNED.
IT'S AS IF YOU EVER SEEN A
SQUIGGLY LINE OR CURSIVE.
WORD AND AND THERE'S A SECURITY
MEASURE LET'S SAY IN YOUR BANK
ACCOUNT THE SAYS SO.
TYPE IN WHAT WORD THIS IS IN A
PROVIDE YOU THE WORD CAT IN
CURSIVE THAT A COMPUTER CAN'T.
UP.
RIGHT SO I GUESS I WAS I AM
SORRY I WASN'T CLEAR BUT SO AS
OF ATTORNEY REPRESENT
CORPORATIONS I KNOW THAT IF THEY
HAVE A QUESTION ABOUT LIABILITY
THEY'RE GONNA BE OVER BROAD.
IN THEIR CREATION OF THIS
TECHNOLOGY TO AVOID LIABILITY
ALLOWING ANY OF THESE POSTS
CALLS THROUGH AND I THINK THAT
IN SO DOING THEY COULD CAPTURE
CALLS LIKE THE ONES WE WANT TO
RETAIN WHICH I THINK WAS ALSO.
THE CONCERN OF MISTER CALDERON
MAYBE A MONTH BUT HOW DO WE MAKE
SURE THAT WE DON'T PUT LIABILITY
ON THEM THAT THEN I WILL.
TAKES AWAY THE POWER OF CALLS
THAT ARE REALLY IMPORTANT OUR
COMMUNITIES.
AND A HOW DO WE DO THAT NOW.
I MEAN WHAT IS WHAT IS STOPPING --
CALLS FROM BEING BLOCK RIGHT NOW
YOU MEANT THEY DID THE RIGHT IN
FRONT OF YOU THEY JUST MENTION
THAT THEY'VE BEEN BLOCK.
A ROBO CALLS.
AND THAT -- THERE ARECURRENTLY
TAKING IN -- MEASURES NOT
COMPLETE MEASURES BUT THEY'RE
TRYING TO THEY'RE TRYING TO
BLOCK BROKE OR BROKE BECAUSE
RIGHT NOW THEY DON'T HAVE A
REQUIREMENT TO DO SO AND ALL
TELECOMMUNICATION COMPANIES MAY
NOT BE DOING IT BUT HOW DO WE DO
THAT NOW HI I DON'T KNOW HOW TO
GET.
THERE THAT'S WHAT WHY WERE KIND
OF IN THIS IN THIS POSITION WE
NEED TO MOVE FORWARD WITH A WITH
WITH A WITH THE PROTECTION
MEASURE BUT HOW DO WE DO THAT
AND PROTECT THE GIVE THEM
[inaudible]
BLANK COMMUNITY.
FROM DOING THAT NOW AND THAT'S
THAT'S KIND OF THE CONCERN.
THAT WE HAVE RIGHT NOW WE HAVE
CALLS ARE COMING IN THAT ARE
GONNA BE JEFF JAMMING UP THE THE
THE TELEPHONE LINES AND THAT HAS --
THERE'S A LIABILITY SUITS SO
STATE WITH THAT TOO BECAUSE THEY
PER THEY PROMISED TO PROVIDE.
YOU TELEPHONE SERVICE.
AND IN IN THAT THEIR PROVIDE --
CALLS ARE GETTING THROUGH THAT
ARE ARE.
ROBIN PEOPLE OF MONEY.
CALLS ARE GETTING THROUGH
MISLEADING PEOPLE ABOUT THEIR
TRUE ORIGINS AND THEIR TRUE
INTENTIONS AND THAT IS ALSO A
LIABILITY THAT THEY HAVE TO DEAL
WITH EVERY DAY SO.
I DON'T KNOW HOW TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS FROM THE HOW WE CREATE
A PERFECT ALL THE PROTECTION
FROM LIABILITY ON ONE SIDE AND
THE OTHER.
AND AND JUST CONTINUES TO BLOCK
THESE CALLS IT'S A DIFFICULT
ISSUE BUT I I'M STILL
SYMPATHETIC TO THEIR POSITION
LIKE YOU ARE.
ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THE BILL
ESSENTIALLY TARGETS THE THE
ADOPTION OF STANDARDS -- TO
BASICALLY HELP SCREEN OUT SOME
OF THESE -- PROBLEMS -- THE R.
EVERYTHING AT MY COLLEAGUE HAS
HAVE SAID I DID OLD -- YOU KNOW
I I THINK THAT MANY OF THESE
CALLS ACTUALLY COME IN DIFFERENT
LANGUAGES EVEN -- YOU KNOW SO I
THINK THE THE THE NEW IMMIGRANTS
ARE EXAMPLES OF THE ELDERLY ARE
PARTICULARLY VULNERABLE TO THESE
CALLS.
BUT I UNDERSTAND ALSO THAT
YOU'RE WORKING ON SOME
AMENDMENTS SO THAT I CAN BE
TAKEN AT THE NEXT STOP CAN YOU
DESCRIBE A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
THE PROPOSAL MADE WELL WE'RE
WORKING ON THAT AND AND IT'S
KIND OF A WORK IN PROGRESS BUT
OUR OUR IDEAS.
TO AGAIN -- TRY TO LIMIT THAT
LIABILITIES MUCH AS POSSIBLE
WERE FOCUSING ON THE LIABILITIES
AS MUCH AS WE CAN.
AND AS I MENTIONED IT'S A WORK
IN PROGRESS.
VERY GOOD.
THE BILL HAS BEEN.
THE BILL'S BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED -- WHICH THE IT
RECOGNITION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS ONE MORE QUESTION
MR GABLE GO AHEAD YEAH I THINK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
I I JUST WANTED TO CLARIFY SOME
OF THE AUTHOR FIRST I WANT TO
COMPLIMENT YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FOR I HAVE -- AS WE IS YOU KNOW
WE DISCUSSED OF A A MEASURE THAT
I THINK IS VERY COMPLEMENTARY I
KNOW THAT EVERYONE HERE PROBABLY.
SHARES OUR CONCERNS ABOUT CALLER
ID SPOOFING IT'S A REAL ISSUE
FOR CONSUMERS IN THE STATE -- I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE UNDERSTAND
THE STEAK THE SHEIK CONSIDER
TECHNOLOGY.
DOES THAT ACTUALLY BLOCK CALLS
OR JUST AUTHENTICATE THEM
INTEL'S PHOTO SYNDICATES CALL
RIGHT SO IT'S NOT ACTUALLY GONNA
BLOCK THE COLLAR ON CALL FROM
THE SCHOOL -- OR FROM A LEDGE OR
FOR ANY WITH SOMEONE THE
DOCTOR'S OFFICE FOR ANYONE WHO'S
THAT THE FIRE DEPARTMENT A
LEGITIMATE USE OF TECHNOLOGY
THAT'S GONNA OPERABLE CALLING
IT'S JUST GONNA HELP YOU HAVE
MORE CONFIDENCE.
THAT WHEN YOU SEE THAT NUMBER
THAT IT'S ACTUALLY FROM WHAT THE
CALLER ID SAYS IT'S FROM THAT'S
CORRECT OKAY THANK YOU THAT'S
OCCURRED.
VERY GOOD WITH THAT THOUGH WHICH
LIKE THE CLOTHES SENATOR -- JUST
SIMPLY.
AGAIN -- IMAGINE A WORLD OR 40%
OF YOUR CALLS.
OUR FRAUDULENT.
AND TRYING TO SCAM YOU OF YOUR
MONEY I THINK WE CAN DO BETTER
AND THAT THE INDUSTRY IS MOVING
TOWARD TECHNOLOGY THAT CAN DO
THIS AND WE JUST WANT.
TO KIND OF YOU KNOW.
MOVE THAT UP AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE
AND I THINK IT'S POSSIBLE AND WE
HAVE OTHER JURISDICTIONS MOVING
FORWARD WITH SIMILAR LAWSON
CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE.
AS THE INNOVATION STATE THE
LEADER IN THIS AREA AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR SUPPORT
TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR --
AND SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
WALL.
CHAO HI SO I KILEY AYE KILEY AYE
BAUER CAJUN BARKING AND I BERMAN.
BERMAN I'D CALDERON CALDERON HI
GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I GALLAGHER [inaudible]
IRWIN.
IRWIN HI OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE AYE SMITH SMITH --
WICKS WICK SO IF TEN VOTES THE
BILL'S AUTHOR THANK YOU PROGRESS
OF NESTING.
THAT'S THE LAST OF THE BILLS SO
LET'S -- GO START FROM THE TOP
IN.
PICK UP.
ALL THE MISSING MEMBER VOTES.
WE CAN START AT ITEM THREE
BECAUSE EVERYBODY WAS HERE FOR
ONE WE JUST DISPENSED WITH
NUMBER TWO OKAY ITEM THREE ITEM
NUMBER THREE SB SIX FORTY EIGHT
CHANGE.
IT'S CALLED THE MISSING.
GOVERNMENT I CALL THEM CALDERON
I GAVE GROW.
GABRIEL I THAT BILLS OUT
[inaudible]
THAT IT -- AND THEN THE CONSENT
CONSENT CALENDAR PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS BERMAN.
BERMAN I CALDERON CALDERON AYE
GABRIEL GABRIEL I GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I THAT DOES IT FOR THE
MEETINGS MEETING IS ADJOURNED